did you know that rihanna's foundation
has donated five million dollars
to assist with coronavirus relief
efforts she is doing good work
and apparently she has a new boo her
medium bff rachel smith joins us from
nashville
with the details you know kev i've been
keeping an eye on ribri because it sure
seemed like something was going on with
asap rocky and now
we've confirmed it
[Music]
according to our et source rihanna and
asap have taken things out of the friend
zone
and they are dating
you can see their smoke and hot
chemistry in their fashion killa video
and our source says they quote always
had amazing chemistry and brianna
relates to asap
it feels natural easy and fun they've
known each other for such a long time so
our babies will be flyer than their
parents
e.t has learned the couple had a date
night with friends this past saturday
inside manhattan's beatrice and
restaurant an eyewitness tells e.t
they had a private vip room where they
enjoyed dinner
so did the pandemic bring them closer
[Music]
in january rihanna broke up with her
billionaire boyfriend of three years
hassan jameel then in july riri featured
asap in her venti skin campaign
check out her reaction when i brought
him up during our interview
i noticed that asap rocky was making a
debut in your campaign and looking
very fine in the process well he's
to me in the industry he's one of the
guys that like everybody
loves the skin i mean i've always wanted
to know like how the heck
do you have better skin than like half
these girls i mean like what what do you
do
what's up riri and there was some next
level flirting going on when they
interviewed each other for gq and vogue
what is your skin type handsome
so is that like an oily hand
a combination enhancement it's a
handsome handsome man
thank you for identifying my beauty as a
man you know what i'm saying
i appreciate you like like real foreign
you